[Musique]
ce mardi 2 juin s'est déroulée au musée
de villèle à saint paul la cérémonie de
remise des médailles d'honneur
départementale une centaine de médailles
argent vermeil et or pour 20 30 et 35
années de service ont été décernées aux
agents du département
le président s'est dit melchior a
remercié chaleureusement les agents pour
leur engagement et leur sérieux au
quotidien et dans leurs missions
respectives
pour moi c'est un grand plaisir mais
aussi un grand honneur que de remettre
cette médaille aux agents du département
j'ai souhaité nouer une relation
particulière avec les agents de la
collectivité parce que j'estime que nous
élus et les agents nous formons une
grande famille
chacun dans son métier il ya près de 200
métiers qui sont exercées par les agents
du département dans ma qualité de
président j'ai le devoir de d'orienter
mais aussi d'un soufflé aussi ce sens du
service public et je le fais avec
plaisir et détermination et je vous
assure que quand je vois les agents
comme ce matin mes côtés je suis un
président heureux de tout ensemble on
est au service des autres et travaillé
ensemble quoi mieux vivre ensemble
c'est ça aussi mon credo
[Musique]